powerful images powerful words from
kendrick lamar
as we welcome you to tnt nba tip-off
presented by
auto trader from studio j here in
atlanta ernie johnson along with
shaquille o'neal and kenny the jet smith
and charles barkley
we're going to spend the first segment
of this pregame show just talking about
this day what it could have been i want
to start with you shaq
with uh your former teammate kobe bryant
and
what would have been birthday number 42
could have been me sending out a tweet
sending out a text calling his mother
to tell him make sure he get the text
calling his father calling the sister
i got a picture in my house i don't know
who did i wish i could find out who did
it they did a photoshop
image of an old me and old kobe it's
right in my living room i say we're
probably in our 60s and 70s
i'm gonna take a picture of that and i'm
gonna bring it tomorrow
but you know i still can't believe it
but the world is doing a great job of
keeping
his memory and keeping his name alive i
see i see stuff on instagram and on
snapchat every day about him so
definitely a legend definitely would
never be forgotten but
i would rather be saying something about
him and him
watching and him sending in a tweet
rather than talking
about him not being here charles
2020 just sucks this has been a tough
year man
it's been a tough year with commissioner
stern
colby the pandemic man 2020 just been an
awful year you know to lose a young man
a father husband at such a young age
and a beautiful daughter and we talked
to the guy on our
podcast who lost his wife matt mauser
matt mouser
and shout out to matt mauser he's a
single father of three now and everybody
else who was on the plane crash talks to
their families
also but man when you lose somebody like
that somebody who you grew up
with and i live in philadelphia during
the summer
i pass laurel marion high school three
to five times a day every time i leave
my condo
and going back for the last 30 years
the first thing i thought about every
day i drive out of that's where kobe
bryant went to high school
i mean i see it every day three or four
times a day and i said oh corbin went to
high school there
and now for him not to be here uh it's
just sad
chet yeah uh echoed you know
i think a lot of us even
contemporaries didn't realize how much
we actually admired him as a player
and um and as a person
until oh my goodness
yeah until um until he actually
passed away and when he passed away i
think the the energy of
how much you really thought about him
and acknowledged him as a player
and as a father and you say you pass the
law on my room every day i i
i go by the mamba center or used to be
mama cena now it's not the mamba anymore
but
the mamba center is where my aau team
aim high practices
so i'd see pictures of him all we we all
get the sweatshirt the mamba mentality
with mamba shirts
and we all kind of you know think about
him daily so um
tragic day but a reflective day as well
you know what i'm
what i'm thinking i want to get to some
thoughts about kobe
but i'm you know i heard you say that
and
this is the kind of game kobe would have
loved to watch the way these two teams
competed the dallas mavericks and the la
clippers and
luca doncic just hit a bucket to win the
game in overtime
it was the kind of effort down 21 and
coming back to win he would have well
the thing appreciated you think about
uh earlier was it this year or last year
when coba was speaking
to luca during the game in his language
yeah and he looked over that he says
corbin brian's speaking my language
uh this would have made kobe proud uh
what i was thinking and i've been doing
a lot of thinking over the past
24 hours or so about losing
your life when you do when he's he's 41
years old he would have been 42 today
um and i'm thinking about what else
is out there in your later years to be
accomplished
and and so first picture
um jack nicklaus 46
when he won his last masters um
spike lee finally got that oscar at the
age of 61.
garrett morgan you know who garrett
morgan was he's the guy who invented
the traffic light with three lights did
that at the age of 46.
grandma moses the renowned
folk artist um didn't pick up a
paintbrush till she was 76
um and it got me thinking too about
the kind of life i've lived and i'm i'm
saying um
i've been broadcasting for 20 years tv
for 20 years before
i got to sit down with you guys and have
the most fun in my life on tv well past
the age of 42. i think about my wife
cheryl
seeing her you know take up the banner
in the fight against sex trafficking
that happened after 42
being the best man at my son eric's
wedding walking my daughter
maggie down the aisle being able to hold
grandkids
shoot i wrote a book that people read
i spoke at my alma mater's commencement
all these things that happened well
after the age of 42
and i just sit here and i say wow
if kobe with his vision and his drive
and his mentality
what would the ensuing years have looked
like
and the impact he would have continued
to make that's what i've been
that's what i've been thinking about the
last 24 hours you have to also think
about it like you think about dr martin
luther king or
something like that what i mean by that
is it doesn't matter how long you live
it matters what you did with your life
yeah like
kobe bryant ain't never going to be
forgotten
i don't like you talking about all that
stuff in the future what he did when he
was here
he ain't never going to be forgotten
same thing with dr king malcolm x guys
like that
those people are iconic and always will
be
so the lesson i would take from your
message is
hey man you got to be do what you do
while you're here in this moment
right now right now and in that mamba
mentality
be better today than you were yesterday
um it is that day it would have been
would have been the 42nd birthday
happy birthday kobe was the instagram
from luca doncic and from king james
[Music]
lakers are going to wear the black mamba
city edition jersey
when they play the portland trailblazers
on monday thanks for that matthew
we'll be back in just a minute